[Music]
it's nine o'clock welcome to our new
show on sky news where i'm going to
interview people who have something to
say about the world and how it's
changing they'll be from politics
business entertainment public life or
they'll be everyday people caught up in
the events of our times but the main
question tonight is what now for the
future of ukraine will this war continue
taking more and more victims or could
there be a way to stop it and with
reports now of streets lined with bodies
and millions of people being forced to
flee their homes should nato countries
be doing more questions i'll be put in
to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening just two weeks ago families
in ukraine lived a normal life they did
the school run they went to work they
had dinner around their kitchen tables
and now whole towns are left flattened
with bombs and missiles raining down
from the skies at least three people
died after maternity hospital was hit
yesterday
in maripol normal life turned to hell on
earth
for two weeks people have been
desperately fleeing their homes with the
simple hope of not getting caught up in
the fighting the un is estimating that
nearly two and a half million people
have left ukraine that's the biggest
mass movement of refugees ever
and now life in russia gets darker too
unprecedented sanctions imposed by
governments from around the world and
private farms from oil and gas companies
to mcdonald's and mother care stage a
mass exodus journalism is criminalized
and the police roam the streets
intimidating and scaring the population
still today the two sides met in what is
the most significant meeting since the
start of the war the russian and
ukrainian foreign ministers sitting down
together in turkey
those who are pumping ukraine with
weapons
they need to understand that they have
responsibility for their actions
a war that upturns decades of peace in
europe and will redefine this century in
all my time in the political arena i've
never before seen our leaders presented
with such a consequential moment in
history
i've got a massive aberration for
vladimir zelensky and i think any leader
in his position
would be saying exactly the same thing
they'd be saying
why can't you
provide that air cover
the once unimaginable is now a lived
reality for all of us i'll be asking
what does the west do now
well tonight we'll have my exclusive
interview with the prime minister
and we're going to be joined here in the
studio by marina litvinenko the widow of
former russian agent alexander
lipvinenko who was poisoned by
radioactive polonium in london
and finally labour mp and mother of the
house harriet harman speaks to me in her
first televised interview since
announcing she's stepping down at the
next election
but now let's turn to our first
interview i traveled to birkenhead in
merseyside today to speak to the prime
minister boris johnson here's my
exclusive
prime minister i i'd like to start this
conversation with the bombing in maripo
yesterday of the children's hospital
putin appears to have committed a war
crime what will it take for the west to
get directly involved in this is killing
children and pregnant women not enough i
think what happened in mariopol in that
maternity hospital really shows that
putin is prepared just to
reject to abandon all norms of of
civilized behavior and the sort of
cynicism with which uh the russian uh
sergey lavrov admitted that they'd
attacked that
maternity hospital shows the the the
depths to which they will stoop and
what we will do of course we are we
already are involved beth in the sense
that uh we are uh from the beginning the
uk was the first european donor of
defensive military equipment we've
massively ramped that up and
what we're doing now is as you can see
is tightening the vice tightening the
the pressure on uh vladimir putin's
regime through economic sanctions and
targeting not just uh swift not just his
banks
but
as many of his people who are known to
be associated with him as as we possibly
can
i i think that you know when you look at
something like the the marriage i mean i
was really i don't know i think many of
many of our viewers must have been
absolutely yeah lavrov said concerns
over civilian casualties were to quote
him pathetic shrieks you know but i'm
afraid that is just where they are and
that is what we're dealing with and i'll
i'll make you one other prediction by
the way which is that the stuff that
you're hearing about
uh chemical weapons is straight out of
their playbook they start saying that uh
there are chemical weapons uh that have
been stored by uh their opponents or by
the americans and so when they
themselves deploy uh chemical weapons as
i as i fear they they may they have us a
a sort of a massacre of a fake story
ready to go you've seen it in syria uh
you you saw it in even in the uk when
this is what you expect next then look i
you know it's i i just note that that is
what they're they're already doing it is
a cynical uh barbaric uh
government i'm afraid and so on your
point about beth on your point about uh
war crimes
i think it's the right question to ask
and
as it happens uh the the law chancellor
the deputy prime minister don raab has a
lot of experience in this he was one of
those uh who was involved in uh putting
slobodan milosevic before the the hague
for trial the the the serb uh leader
uh
for for war crimes and
he will be going off to to the hague to
see what uh
they need what what evidence we can help
but in the meantime prime minister the
bombing of attorney hospital at least
516 civilians have been clear killed the
use of cluster bombs thermobaric weapons
the threat of chemical weapons troops
opening fire on fleeing families
shelling of civilian humanitarian
corridors airstrikes on residential
blocks is it not on your conscience
every time you speak to president
zielenski and he asks you for that
no-fly zone it must
it is
and it's terrible i gotta say it's
absolutely terrible and
i've got a massive aberration for
vladimir zelensky and i think any leader
in his position
would be saying exactly the same thing
they'd be saying
why can't you provide that air cover why
can't you as the west uh simply help to
clear our skies of
russian planes and stop us being
bombarded from the air stop this this
evil going on in europe and and you know
we've had some some
very frank conversations and ones in
which which have been deeply
upsetting
the difficulty is that well the
difficulty is that uh there is a
there is a line
uh beyond which
quite frankly the the uk nato would be
would be deemed to be
in conflict direct conflict so there's
no russia so no circumstances if they if
as you say
they could uh drop chemical weapons is
that not the red light nothing well is
there nothing
that could happen that might make you
change your mind it's agonizing it's
absolutely agonizing and i've had this
conversation uh
at least a couple of times now with with
vladimir
but i think the difficulty is that it
would require me
to order
raf jets uk pilots
into the air with a mission
to shoot down russian fast jets
and that is something that
all my life
literally all my life all my childhood i
remember something that we uh we did
everything we possibly could to avert
because that would be conflict between
a p5 nuclear powers
no circumstances no circumstances that
can that happen is that well i think
we've got to be realistic and we're
going to do everything we can to
support the ukrainian people to support
uh the
amazing heroic ukrainian resistance and
we're doing more and more uh with uh
support from uh from with their with uh
their defenses uh with anti-tank
weaponry and all that kind of thing i
don't want to go into the the details
but i think i think our viewers know
roughly what we're we're doing it has
been it has been ramped up but there is
that is that is effectively a defensive
okay but i just want to stress that
there's no western country i know where
that is that is on the agenda well you
speak to president zlensky a lot every
time you put the phone down to him do
you wonder whether that might be the
last conversation that you'll have here
i think i think vladimir has been one of
the uh most extraordinary leaders of
recent times in the way he's rallied
he's only rallied his people he's
rallied the whole world to the cause of
ukraine and he's made us all wear uh
yellow and blue
flags and he's got ev he's got everybody
mobilized on his side i think
because he's so clearly and and
and brilliantly delineated the
difference between right and wrong in
this case everybody can see that this is
an unjustified act of aggression he did
an interview in on sky news last night
he said he thinks millions of people
could die do you think millions of
people could die in this conflict i
think that it depends on putin and it's
up to him and to him alone and that
everybody can see that things aren't
progressing in the way that uh he hoped
prime minister and
and his best bet i think
is to withdraw uh to cease the uh the
violence and uh and and to allow
a peaceful negotiation to begin let's go
on to vladimir putin two weeks into this
war it's already unbearable to see the
images coming out of the ukraine your
foreign secretary said it could last a
decade do you agree with that
i think that
again that depends on
on putin
but what i certainly think is that the
uh ukrainians themselves
and the
will to resist in ukraine will never be
extinct i get that but how is it going
to go on for you
my own view is that
uh
vladimir putin can
either choose to accept that he's made a
catastrophic mistake now
or except that he's made a catastrophic
mistake a bit later on and that's the
that's the difference between the two
options he faces how long
that is i'm afraid up to the
kremlin like you know i wish i
better i wish i wish that the
that i could tell you how long it will
be i think that you know he has said uh
that he wants to give the military
operations till the end of this month
you've heard what putin's own narrative
is i myself don't believe i don't think
most people looking at the situation uh
believe
he i don't think that he can he can
conquer ukraine
but prime minister you keep saying that
putin must fail i do
but do you acknowledge that putin in his
mind must be seen to win
that's the problem you keep saying he's
going to fail but he has to win so how
do we get out of this i i think that he
i think that he needs to understand
that his options are not good are not
good but you accept that that he needs
to have some sort of victory what's the
off ramp well when you say when you say
needs uh that that i don't know what you
quite mean by means
is that uh
the best way out for for russia for the
russian people
uh is for
withdrawal of the russian
forces and
uh for
total
cessation of hostilities
uh for reparations and i think
we will all have to work together to
rebuild ukraine
be in no doubt but uh that's that's just
that's just the beginning but you accept
that you won't be able to i think you i
think you've put your finger on
something very important which is that
i think that vladimir putin has himself
made it very difficult to
find an off-ramp and he has i think
driven his
uh his tanks so to speak down a
cul-de-sac from which it will be very
hard to extricate himself but but he
must but in the meantime millions of
people are going to die so how do you
help him get an offer up i mean what's
the compromise what's the compromise
should
ukraine say okay we'll withdraw
application for nato or i mean what
all i i guess want to say is all i see
is escalation and i understand the
sanctions and but there's it's
escalating there's no de-escalation and
in the meantime millions of people could
die i think what needs to happen first
of all is that putin needs to understand
that he's made a catastrophic
miscalculation and he needs to to
withdraw he needs to stop killing
innocent people in in ukraine i i then
think that uh there is
certainly a space for a conversation
about the future but
it's got to be in those in that context
and it's got to be something that uh the
people of of ukraine and uh the
ukrainian government actively wants beth
and i think this is the crucial thing i
don't think that you can have a
conversation
about ukraine without ukraine they've
got to be they've got to be at the table
but it does seem to me they've got to be
they've
i can't see a way out that doesn't begin
with the realization uh by
the uh the kremlin they've made a
catastrophic mistake and that it's time
to to begin uh to withdraw and stand
withdraw immediately so
let me just move on to sort of domestic
response and your leadership over that
um
in terms of sanctions today you finally
sanctioned roman abramovich and six
other oligarchs something people have
been calling for for for a couple of
weeks now uh it's been welcomed but do
you acknowledge you could have moved
more quickly on this and you wish you
had i think the uk has been absolutely
out in front in uh the whole sanctions
process and don't just listen to to me
listen to what the uh the ukrainians
have said look at what the kremlin
themselves have said about the uk's role
in this we drove
you drove the sanctions
on central bank
on those individuals don't forget that
we've already done uh two or three
hundred
individuals and in the uk we have uh
pretty tight protections of uh
of property rights uh from tuesday uh
we'll be able to go
uh
much further and fast because we're
changing the law under the economic
crime bill what we've been able to do
with the individuals who've been
sanctioned today is to look at their
relationship
with the russian
regime
the due process has been gone through uh
all the evidence has been assembled
which is the right thing to do and
they've been sanctioned and uh in a very
tough way but that's the that's the way
we've had to do it when you campaign to
take back control was it so that when we
have issues like ukraine crisis that you
can be more restrictive than the
european union when it comes to visas no
because if you look at what we're we're
doing we're historically and and uh by
nature a a very very generous and uh
open welcoming people but we've only
wanted to only issued a thousand people
well that was the number yesterday and
i'm it's rising the whole time and it
will rise
uh on monday uh you'll get from the
uh from uh from the leveling up
secretary uh you'll get uh the program
that will allow people to come in so
people people want to welcome it into
their own homes
they can do so you ask about well i know
you've checks i know you've said about
checks in the need for biometric testing
but half of the refugee half of the two
million refugees
estimated to believe a children you
don't need to biometrically test a child
i mean it seems a bit heartless someone
actually said to me yesterday a cabbie
he said it's really heartless why don't
they just wave the visa checks
i'll tell you why so so for for younger
people
were not being uh as uh we're not making
those requirements but what we are doing
is in ensuring that uh
and i think this is the best thing also
for for refugees because they want a
scheme that is safe uh that is welcoming
and that works and
if you've been to uh war zones and as
i'm sure you have as as i have you'll
know all sorts of things are going on
there and and you and you'll you'll find
that um
uh there are people coming out of them
who perhaps uh for one reason or another
don't have the the papers that uh they
need and may even have false papers they
may have a good reason for that but it
is sensible given the uh
the attitudes of the putin regime
towards the uk uh it is sensible to have
uh to have checks so by the end of the
year and they are they are like
thousands
checks but i think that most people can
see the case prime minister i've got so
many more questions
on the numbers it could go up yeah uh
you know just on the family reunion
thing uh you could have a very large
number indeed because there are so many
potential uh
uh
beneficiaries of that scheme and that's
great but i mean as i said in the
comments yesterday i'm proud as is the
as is dom rob as the deputy prime
minister as is uh the home secretary
where all the direct descendants of of
refugees
our government
has done a lot if you look at the people
we took from afghanistan uh the numbers
we've taken
from hong kong from hong kong
so i know what i view our viewers will
want to know because what the brief
people want to know is are we going to
be generous and my answer is
overwhelming okay well yeah we'll talk
about that
because at the moment we haven't done
very well i think the public are a bit
annoyed i also think people want us uh
to have chance yeah but i think people
are annoyed that we haven't done more i
think people think i think people you
must accept that i think people people
want
us to be generous but they also want us
to be the final question i had for you
and this is about you leveling with the
british people about the cost at home of
this yes okay energy bills could go up
to 3000 by 3 000 pounds uh
oil prices i mean do you even know what
the cost of a liter of petrol now is
um how bad is it going to be can you
just level with people let me just pain
they're going to have to take so we will
do everything so we've frozen the fuel
duty for instance for
for 12 years and and we will continue to
to do that um we will do everything we
can to help households help people with
the cost of fuel particularly uh elderly
vulnerable people and you you you know
all the packages of of support we're
putting in even more that the chancellor
announced the the other day
that's not going to be enough on its own
so uh the best thing for dealing with
the cost of living i mean big picture
yeah is to have
a strong economy
good high-wage high school jobs such as
those such as the ones that we're
creating throughout with our
shipbuilding strategy which you which
you haven't mentioned uh even though
we're in this uh this shipyard
you could have done but i'm going to
mention it
i'm going to just slide it in there
this is the the this is the this is that
we are launching our international
shipwreck we're here in camel laird
and so but what we're also going to do
and this is
absolutely vital
not just have a high wage high skill
economy uh with with with record
employment and almost record low youth
unemployment which is a great thing uh
what we're going to do is look at our
energy supply and what putin is doing
is proving how wrong we were in 2014
not to move away
as europeans and the uk did more than
other european countries
but we could do still more to move away
from dependence on russian oil and gas
and so so what i'm saying to you beth is
that now is the time and it may be a
bumpy uh period but we will get through
it as fast and as well as we possibly
can now is the time to unleash an
extraordinary program of energy
independence
through through a massive investment in
renewables
in more nuclear
a lot more nuclear and also in sensible
use of our own
hydrocarbons with our own oil and gas
and without busting our carbon we're
going to have to take the pain we're
trying to defeat putin aren't we and so
and
so
yes i think that is right i think that
the
absolutely right beth i think that the
west is going to have to learn the
lesson of indulging and appeasing putin
and failing
to wean ourselves off russian oil and
gas and we are now going to do the
dramatic steps that we need to take to
have independent energy supply so that
we're no longer capable of being
blackmailed by putin and that i think is
the right thing to do prime minister
thank you very much thank you
the prime minister there with a deeply
concerning warning that russia might use
chemical weapons next in ukraine doesn't
they're thinking about stay with us
because coming up next i'll be joined
live by marina litvinyenko the widow of
ex-russian agent alexander lipvinenko
who died in london from radioactive
polonium poisoning
[Music]
welcome back when former russian spy
alexander litvinienko died in london in
2006
from radioactive poisoning it shocked
the world that such an attack could
happen on british soil since then russia
has been was found responsible for his
death well with me now is alexander's
widow marina lipvinenko who is in exile
living here in london marina thanks so
much for joining us tonight on my first
show i really appreciate it um
now let's kick off with your recent
holiday you were in ukraine as i
understand it uh just in the run-up uh
to the invasion i think you left just
after the invasion you're with your
friends
what was the atmosphere like
and how are your friends and first of
all very good evening and shall i start
with a very special words glory to
ukraine
ukrainian this is very important to all
ukrainian to hear it and to all people
who support ukraine now
when i went to ukraine i know it's a
very tense
situation in a board
from sight of russia was very much uh
unexplained and unexpectable and
everybody discussed would be this war or
not but i decided to go 16th of february
because i thought
it's a good time to to have a nice time
in the very west of ukraine what is a
very peaceful
very beautiful area
and i didn't think i would be in ukraine
and i received this news war has started
in the same moment all the small town
was mobilized it was not panic it was
not history everybody tried to receive
news from their relatives in the east of
part in ukraine from kiev from kharkov
it was shocking news
and this small town expected this all
refugees immediately
and started to think how they could
accommodated them how they could bring
them to the port if they decide to
travel to poland or to another country
people wonder how could they
help refugees did they start arming
themselves did they
this was all just uh i would say people
were ready for something
worse but of course they didn't want it
but they've been ready for this because
this was a lot of organizing of
self-defense organization when all men
were ready to go to this
people went to special station to give
their blood even i went to do this so
you gave blood so everyone went to build
the blood supply
yes and this was so many people it looks
like this old town was ready to give
their old blood to these soldiers to
casualties to anybody did putin
miscalculate the ukrainian people's
spirit 100
i think 2014 give them to putin and to
his alliance justices wrong message
ukrainian people soft they're not going
to fight and like in crimea just will
say welcome
and would be happy to be part of russia
but it was wrong
and how are you friends now
uh it's still quite a serious but this
part is okay it's in the west so it's
very western and i think the areas of
conflict yet yes it's even not leave
this is more close to slovakia border to
poland to hungary but people in kiev in
a very serious situation i have very
good friend of mine a member of a
ukrainian radha and she is she's a woman
and a young very promising politician
she's fighting with kalashnikov
and maria let's talk about your late
husband alexander sasha as
you
knew him all spoke of him um i think
we've got a wedding photo actually of
you
uh
there you are um can you see it there
marie it's on the screen yes isn't that
a lovely that's gorgeous huh um i just
want to ask you about a letter that
sasha wrote an open letter to putin two
days before he died you you'll know this
off your heart
he said you may succeed in silence in
one man but the howl of protests from
around the world mr putin will
reverberate in your ears for the rest of
your life
when did sasha realize that putin was
bad for russia from very beginning
and when he stand up in 1998
against of all this corruption and
security service it was his first fight
against vladimir putin because he would
he was put to prison and spent almost
one year
and then when he escaped he published a
book blowing up russia about apartment
bombing when he openly accused of
security service to do this crime
against russian people because they want
to show putin is a strong man and he
will defend all ordinary russian people
what was not true
and his second book was just explained
everything that happened in
fsb
successor of kgb and this was all his
what he tried to prevent and marina do
you you obviously have friends in russia
still that you talk to
do you think that russian people
understand what's what's going on or do
you think that because of the media
restrictions that they don't really know
what's happening in ukraine from your
experience of talking to people it's
it's not even restrictions it's
completely brainwashed and some people
just afraid to think about truth
they may be understood something very
bad happening in ukraine but they're
afraid to talk about this because they
they can't believe that this is really
happening they're afraid of the truth
because you need to
accept you live in the country who's
aggressor and this is very difficult and
sometimes they started to defend
putin defends
all these actions
marina do you think that the russian
people might eventually overthrow putin
or is it so repressive there that it's
it's not possible we don't know soviet
union collapsed in 1991 when nobody
believe it because it was the strongest
country and opposition to all as a world
and now yes it's a different one but i
don't think it's as strong as it was
soviet union yes they tried to control
everybody every individual but we still
have people outside in the street which
is all processed and marina can i just
ask you as well you've lived in in
britain you're adopted country since
2000 so over two decades now are you
happy with the way that britain has
responded to the crisis
now of course it's much better than it
did happened before and the every time
cry for this you have to do something
now it's a huge international support
and it's this united country in the
european union united kingdom america
and other other countries what is very
important for putin it was always
very important to make these all
countries to work separately to divide
everyone exactly and so now he will be
confounded or confused by the fact that
you west has united he might not have
anticipated it's another surprise for
him
do you think that we're taking enough
refugees
i don't think so and we know this
picture from colors in paris when people
need to go back to
apply for visa
it's a shame because i saw these people
spend hours and hours to get through
ukrainian board and then go to see maybe
their relatives here in uk and i would
like to say these people don't want to
get out from ukraine they pushed from
ukraine yes and they're not looking for
better life they definitely come back
when it would be all finished so you
would like
our prime minister to follow the
european union and introduce visa
waivers for the people of ukraine
absolutely because you will save these
people and they will all time grateful
for this and just finally
do you think that
politicians here made a mistake in
welcoming russian oligarchs so warmly to
the uk in the past
of course we need to learn all mistakes
for what we did and of course uh
politicians play this
uh i would say ruthless because you
should it should be checked and money
and people who've been accepted here and
now we should talk about not a past we
should
talk about present and about future not
to make more mistakes okay maureen i
would i'd love to carry on but i've run
out of time thank you so much for coming
on it was it was a pleasure
well look uh stay with us because coming
up next the mother of the house harriet
harmon on why she's stepping down as an
mp and the reflections on losing her
husband jack tromey
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back this week's been one to
celebrate women with international
women's day on tuesday it's a time to
recognize the achievements of women
around the world in politics it's been
and often still is a fight to get
women's voices hard and one of the women
who's been leading that fight in british
politics for four decades is labour mp
harriet harman she's the mother of the
house of commons which means she's the
longest serving female mp still sitting
and earlier i spoke to her in her first
television interview since announcing
her retirement
harriet thanks for coming on the show
you became an mp in 1982 and it was
against the backdrop of mass protest
against nuclear weapons the women at
greenham common it ended up with
thousands of people protesting across
the uk
and now as you prepare to stand down as
an mp
40 plus years on
we've got this moment where president
putin has put his nuclear weapons back
on alert
and i wondered what that made you think
as if we've gone back 40 years back to
the cold war back to a world that we
thought maybe was in our past
well i think that the path we've tried
to go on since then is to stop the
proliferation
of nuclear weapons of having more and
more countries becoming nuclear
countries and to reduce the
nuclear arsenal of those those
superpowers that did have nuclear
weapons but it is one of the most
frightening in amongst the horrific
things that's
happened with putin's invasion and
harriet you've been a lifelong supporter
of labor labour values of
internationalism what do you think's the
principal position to take on ukraine
that they should fight tooth and nail to
liberate their country that there should
be an immediate ceasefire and talks
leading to a compromise what should we
be doing well i think what we should be
doing is what we are doing which is
saying that they are absolutely right
and entitled to defend themselves and
putin is absolutely wrong to invade we
just have to be absolutely clear about
that um and do everything we can to
support them
in in their fight against putin which is
a defense of themselves a war that as
president zielinski said to us in the
house of commons yesterday a war that
they did not start and they did not want
what was it like in the commons
yesterday
well
it was a bit chilling really because
it it drew to your attention how
how safe and secure we are in the house
of commons in london
in the uk and we saw president zielinski
in such a position of jeopardy with
hundreds if not thousands of his people
being killed and millions fleeing under
attack from
from a nuclear power i think it just
showed the stark contrast and harriet um
you obviously support cirque stammer's
position but it has stoked division in
the party 11 mps signed electro accused
in nature of sabre rattling and then
kirsten threatened those mps with
suspension
labor's always been a broad church do
you think it was a bit aggressive
to sort of threaten people with
suspension oh not at all i think that if
you're the leader you have to have a
clear position and you need to make sure
the party has a clear position and the
labour party does have a clear position
which is we support nato and we support
ukraine and we couldn't have people who
were labour mps somehow qualifying that
so i think he was right i mean one of
the things about leadership is yes
listen to and include a broad range of
views but in this sort of situation you
have to be decisive and that's what he
was the reason i wanted to get you on
the show was it was international
women's
day uh this week you have been
the most prominent feminist campaigner
in politics from for many decades
actually
um you're the longest servant female mp
you're the true trailblazer and i
remember a few years back when i was
talking to a conservative mp about
getting more conservative women on the
benches they said we need a harmon
figure because you drove through
such change and i think we've got a
picture somewhere
of uh
1997 and blair's babes do you remember
that can you see yourself there do you
remember that green yes yeah yeah with
tony blair and there's the late momolan
in front of you
uh you were behind all women's
shortlists what was it like back then
when you had this breakthrough
i think it was incredible because it was
a time when
women were just saying we're fed up with
being regarded as second-class citizens
you know we're fed up with the idea that
you know men should run the show and
women should abide by everything that
men say
and that we were fed up with being
excluded from you know all walks of life
including political journalism um and
so to have that breakthrough and to have
women in the house of commons
representing a country which is 50 women
was a very important moment and you know
as we went around you know if you went
to the supermarket or you just went out
and about in the street people would
come up and say it's fantastic women
would come up and say it's fantastic to
see you there in the house of commons
because otherwise previously had just
been a sea of great grey suits there was
97 men and only 3 women and parliament
was just downright unrepresentative and
that affected the public policy agenda
you know we've still got
a way to go um yeah we've still got a
way to go and women are written on equal
terms the obvious question there's no
ever been a female leader of the labour
party the conservative party had two
female prime ministers you know
some people might say that labour has a
bit of a woman problem is that fair well
we certainly got a woman problem in
terms of never having a woman leader
which is downright embarrassing and next
time although we're not going to be
having a leadership election anytime
soon next time we do need a woman leader
but that's how would your money be on
oh i you know honestly i'm not gonna i'm
gonna let the future mps and you know
party members choose that but the other
thing is it can't be taken away from
labor that we did lead the way
and we did by ensuring we had all those
labour women mps then the other parties
began to look quite old-fashioned as men
only preserves so they followed in that
path let's move on to another area um
which i know you've campaigned on and
can care deeply about which is violence
against women and girls because again
this is a very poignant and
relevant issue at the moment
we've recently had the anniversary of
the abduction and murder of sarah
everett that moment that lit a touch
paper in this country where thousands of
women came out to protest against
violence against women and girls rape
cases that are record light high
prosecution's a record low
when when i interviewed the home
secretary
she said all of us at some stage in our
lives have been subject to all sorts of
harassment is she right have you
i think there's not a woman in this
country who hasn't at some point at some
part of her life been followed down the
street um been harassed um on public
transport
have been
sexually harassed at work i mean it's
just every woman's universal experience
and what's happening now
oh i mean i was
sexually harassed at work when i was a
trainee solicitor you know like every
school girl if i walk down the street i
was always looking over my shoulder and
you know men would follow along in cars
and that's still happening today but
what is different today is that women
are rightly saying we're not going to
put up with this anymore we want curb
crawling to be an offense we don't want
there to be impunity for men
who rate women and say well she said no
but she actually meant yes so i think
that what is
really important now is that women are
no longer prepared to put up with what
all of us have put up with
and also
that
when i was being sexually harassed at
work in my twenties
there was no question of any complaint
about it did you absolutely what did
nothing said nothing to anybody what did
you do to the man or what did you just
try and avoid him or what i i shrieked
because he kind of came up and grabbed
me from behind
and but it wouldn't have occurred to me
to be able to complain because he was
senior
and
was you know my sort of line manager and
my
future
career completely dependent depended on
not being chucked out and all the
partners would have sided with him and i
would have been regarded as a
troublemaker it's the same old same old
story that every woman do then just
avoid him yeah just yeah just be well
it's sometimes very difficult to avoid
somebody especially you have to work in
the same room as them just the two of
you on your own but i think the thing is
now that there are an expectation
there's an expectation there should be
complaint systems that they should be
independent that women can complain
anonymously so that they don't expose
themselves to victimization and that
they shouldn't have to be frightened on
the street and people talk about women
not feeling at risk but it's women are
at risk so what needs to be tackled
is the sense amongst men that they can
harass women and that that's just banter
or they can get away with it and harriet
finally let's let's come on to
uh
you and your decision to step down
um
you announced in december you're going
to step down after 42 years of being an
mp
and then since you took that decision
obviously your world was turned upside
down
with the sudden loss of your husband and
fellow mp jack jeromey and i i want to
say again how sorry we we all are thank
you about that harriet um
a week ago there was the by-election in
in birmingham birmingham ardenton which
was was jack's seat was that was that
really difficult for you how was that i
think it would have been really
difficult if we hadn't have won the seat
and returned a labour mp
i mean jack was born and brought up a
catholic and he always said he was
lapsed but he never quite got uh
beyond the notion of an afterlife and
i'm sure he he certainly would be
thinking he was up there looking down
and he would have
been horrified if there'd been anything
other than a labour mp following in his
footsteps so
um
it's good to welcome paulette as as the
new labour mp and just and just on your
on your enduring decades of a long
partnership you've got three children
you've got five grandchildren you just
told me you've got a sixth on the way so
you're going to be very busy
um
jack described you quite rightly as the
outstanding parliamentary feminist of
her generation and he said he was in all
of you
while you in the house of commons
you talked about jack being a superpower
who made us all walk taller and feel
stronger
does the strength of what you had
together kind of give you the strength
to affect to face the future now because
it must be
very discombobulating but i think if
you've lived with that sort of domestic
propaganda it can't help but you know
reinforce your confidence and all of us
get imposter syndrome from time to time
and think that we can't do things so to
have that
relentless positivity and belief
is incredible but it wasn't just me that
was the beneficiary of that positivity
and belief
that there are you know women in the
trade union that he
worked in
other women in parliament that he would
always be encouraging because he
believed that a role of men was to
support and encourage women and not to
stand in their way and and hold them
back so
i am left with surely that confidence
that has been built up all of those
years but you know we were together for
for 47 years uh which is an incredibly
long time to share your political
journey and your life's journey with
somebody and
the thing about being a widow after a
long marriage is that i mean my mum
lived till she was a hundred so i might
have another 30 years left so this is a
a new chapter in my life which i've got
to
figure out
how to crack on with the things that i'm
going to be doing for the next 30 years
and you know people say oh now that
you're on your own but
i'm i'm not with jack anymore but i'm
not on my own i've got my children i've
got my friends i've got my work
colleagues
and
i don't agree with the notion that
somehow that's out there that
when you're a widow
your life is effectively over that the
best years of your life are behind you
and somehow you're a lesser person
i think that we've got to recognize that
it's a different stage of life
and obviously it starts with great grief
and loss
but
people can be you know they are
themselves in widowhood same as they are
themselves
the rest of their life
and has it changed how you
approach stepping down as a
parliamentarian because presumably
your next 30 years are going to be
different now did you think about
carrying on working no i haven't changed
my mind about standing down i've been an
mp for for decades and for each day of
those decades i felt a great sense of
responsibility for my constituents for
my role in parliament but at the end of
the day you can't carry on indefinitely
and i want to go when i'm still fully
committed and doing the job to the best
of my ability and you know i'll see
what's on the other side of stepping
down from having those magic letters mp
after my name well i'm sure that you
will be doing many more interesting
things and i think your grandchildren
can be keeping you very busy anyway
harriet thanks so much for coming on the
show
well that's all for today's show thank
you to all our guests harriet harmon
marina litvinyenko and of course boris
johnson and thank all of you uh for
joining us tonight later tonight you'll
be able to get the beth rigby interviews
podcast with all the highlights of this
show and a few behind the scenes bits
too and you can find that on the sky
news app or you can subscribe to it
wherever you get your podcast from
coming up on sky news at 10 mark hosting
is live in la viv with more on the war
in ukraine
[Music]
you